Terry good afternoon to you and yours is
an extreme example of isolation remind
viewers what happened nearly 29 years
ago now well it is a long time ago I was
working in those days as a hostage
negotiator and I negotiated way back
with Jim Alamein with revolutionary
guards with Colonel Qaddafi and when you
do a dangerous job like that you always
know in the back of your mind something
if you go wrong and in my case it did go
wrong in Beirut and I found myself in
captivity first of all in an underground
cell which was beneath a car park
a tired cell and then later on in a
bombed-out building in the upper floors
of a bombed out building I slept on the
floor
I had no books or papers for almost four
years when anyone came in the room I had
to pull a blank fold over my eyes and
there were metal shutters put in front
of the window if I was upstairs so no
natural light came in and I occasionally
had electric light but not always often
in the dark and there was no one to
speak with nothing I was chained to the
wall by the hands and feet for 23 hours
and 15 minutes a day I remember that
distinctly I had about five minutes each
day to go to the bathroom so it was a
case of extreme isolation and solitary
living yeah 1736 days you're on your own
and as you mentioned you were
blindfolded for love at that time so for
around four and a half years you didn't
actually see another person mentally how
did you deal with that well the first
thing you have to do is to come to terms
with with anger in my case and many
people at the moment will be at home and
the many people who be deep they're
worried because they'll be worried about
their jobs they'd be worried about
you chilly they worried about the family
very very understandable that had my
sympathy and I was worried I was worried
about my own family I was worried about
my own situation would I live because
you know eventually I was I was tortured
not severely but I'm better now if I can
tell you and I did have a mock execution
and so I had to come to terms with with
that those extreme feelings just as I
say people have to come to terms with
those type of feelings today and the way
to do that in part is to try and live
for the moment try and live for now try
and make the moment as full as possible
now how do you do that in captivity when
you've no book should no papers of
nothing well I had to do that by
mentally adjusting to the situation
saying there is little or nothing I can
do to change this but I can hold on to
the fact that I have life now not
tomorrow I have it now and I'm going to
live it as fully as possible I began to
write in my head I've begun to use my
mental capacity in a way and extend that
and that was a way of just surviving and
as I say there were many people who are
deeply afraid and deeply worried at the
moment well somehow remember that this
virus will be defeated there will be a
life after that and you know things do
have a habit of turning out well if we
want to work for them for the majority
of us it will be fine but we just
somehow have to develop that capacity
within ourselves to take the situation
at the moment as it is yeah it's
interesting isn't it it's about
reframing the way we think I mentioned
earlier it's about being well saying
things like we're safe at home rather
than we're stuck at home and and
changing our mindset you actually took
quite a lot of positives out of your
time in solitude and as we've said it's
such an extreme and dark example but
even you found the positives in your
situation
well yes I mean what what I had to do
also was try and keep myself I don't
they keep myself alive in the following
way I mean I tell you a silly story but
it's perfectly true in the first week of
captivity I have my own clothes and at
night I mentioned get my trousers off
even though I was checking out and I put
them under the mattress to press them
now that may sound really stupid it's
something I learned in the Army I was at
the end of national service and
something I learned that in all these
situations keep your own dignity keep
yourself smart and the same applies
today in the sense when those people are
at home in in sort of lockdown you know
don't just get up and hang around all
day in a dressing gown or pajamas take a
pride in your appearance still keep
yourself smart keep yourself retain your
own dignity that's that's really pretty
important the other thing to say is form
a structure for the day now there are
I'm sitting here now I'm in lockdown at
the moment I've been alone for the past
we made maybe a bit longer but I'm so
fortunate
I mean I'm surrounded by my box am
surrounded by papers I've got access
through the internet I've got a whole
range of things and I can use this time
creatively which I'm trying to do I'm
actually beginning to start to write a
new book at the moment but I can use it
creatively and that's what again we have
to say well what is there in this
situation that we can take and use
creatively rather than emphasizing the
negative and that's important and also
at the moment of course some time ago I
founded an organization called a hostage
international and it's particularly hard
for those families you know who got
someone who's taken hostage and they
have no idea where they are and they're
trying to cope with a family with young
children well what is International
gives families of
I'm in contact with them throughout this
period with many families at any given
time there's something like 2,000 people
in the world 10 ostrich and there are
all sorts of people in these extreme
situations who you know are coping that
they need help and they need support and
where you don't have it where you don't
have that you have to find it from
within yourself and it is possible to
find it familiar yourself for the
majority of people teri you tell such an
inspirational tale given what you've
gone through but you know everything is
relative people will take things from
what you're saying and apply it to their
own situations at home because many
people aren't able to see their loved
ones many people are on their own what
do you think we'll have learnt as a
society when we come out the other side
of this well I remember a few years ago
a politician saying there was no such
thing of society well I think that's
been proved to be absolutely wrong I'm
here in Suffolk you know in a small
village now we are we are very very
fortunate because there was a good sense
of community on Saturday I need you some
shopping doing on Sunday morning someone
left a bag of shopping at my front door
I heard yesterday that the local church
through a charity has organised a system
of distributing meals for those that
need it and in all sorts of ways people
are responding I think the the British
people it brief at the time like this
often brings out the best in people it
brings out the worst in some people
we've had examples of that but but
overall it brings out the best and what
I hope will happen is that we'll have a
new sense of community of society when
we've been through this and in fact even
going much further than that
perhaps we'll have a new understanding
that we need to be into and in touch
with our environment in a way that
perhaps we haven't been in the past you
know we've gone into all sorts of policy
building on Greenbelt there
this that and the other we've got to
need our agricultural land we're going
to need to support our farmers we're
going to need to support our grow our
own crops and grow our own food perhaps
a new world order is coming into being
if it is I hope it's a world order that
will mean that there will be greater
justice and fairness for all people in
the world and at the moment what has
happened is in some strange sort of way
we've all been leveled we've all been
seen that we're all human beings and
we're all vulnerable and that if we can
learn that we've got to be in touch and
in - with our environment and determined
to do that in the future we shall all be
the much better off forward yeah Terry
we're all in this together Terry wait a
pleasure to speak to you from your home
in Suffolk where you yourself ice lasing
I'd better crack on with that book thank
you very much more time where was Tiny's
this afternoon like